ho detto non stack e bevande
bentornati su anita state oggi
nuovissimo episodi trovo nascondere gli
snack al cinema senza essere scoperto
dal controllore lo scorso episodio vi è
piaciuto tantissimo gli ho scritto un
sacco di consigli avete lasciato
tantissimi l'ice infatti se anche questo
episodio di raggiungere i 20 mila mi
piace ci sarà un terzo episodio con
altri trucchetti super divertente e
iniziamo subito con il primo round
[Musica]
ecco il trucchetto per il primo round ok
ti non c'è niente ancora voi starete
pensando ma metterei snack nella tasca
no perché ce ne sarebbero pochi e poi
lui controllerebbe le tasse se ne
accorgerebbe subì quindi lasceremo le
tasche vuote così lui 6 controllerò le
tanti penseranno sono vuote allora non
nasconde niente ma andremo a nascondere
gli snack e diranno che non se ne
accorga
quindi attacca rovaris mac con lo scotch
scuole e con lo scotch qua berlino ma
stavolta non malissimo st pesato ma che
stai facendo
mi sono dimenticato di dirvi se non mi
seguite su instagram adatte a seguirmi
il nome di the stories se volete stima
che mi ha anche su tik tok
l'organizzazione merlino che i pezzi
secondo te riusciremo a vincere laziale
giu questa volta a roma come non berlino
non credi in me mi raccomando degli
alleati con me non con il controllore li
lavo bravo che abbiamo come il the knack
come sempre abbiamo i pop corn e lo
snack più vuole
eccola gli snack che il primo anno
scatterà sembra il giorno della befana
quando aprì la casa disney che poi li
mangi tutto il giorno a pezzetti valeri
vedevo ora inizierò ad attaccarli qua
altri sperando che non cadano devo stare
attenta a non attaccare cose troppo
pesanti altrimenti potrebbe scoprirmi
che riguarda te ci sto riuscendo
attaccato queste cose con lo scotch che
sembra che abbia funzionato bene
purtroppo possa attaccare solo cosa è
leggere perché altrimenti le cose
pesanti che avrebbero quindi ora vado
attaccare quel collettivo
sembra che funzioni ragazzi guardate non
si vede niente e 321 seccandone
riusciremo a vincere questo turno e
secondo voi
l'importante è che io stia molto attenta
a non farli cadere
potevo anche cercare di non fare rumore
abbiamo subito al cinema e vediamo se
riusciamo a superare questo toro
[Musica]
favorisca il biglietto per favore
ah sì eccolo qua te posso andare adesso
no il suo film della saub o ok tuttavia
lei cosa nel tour botto che vuol dire
che questo non sento dei rumori strani
ha per caso con sé cibo penale
no mi faccio vedere le tasche della
gente
anche quindi possono anche andare
signorina non mi dica che sta
nascondendo qualcosa è come proprio
vedere qui c'è scritto qui niente
bevande e snack
ma per quale motivo indosso un
impermeabile non piove mica all'interno
delle sale lo sanno benissimo che non
piove all'interno del cinema ma io non
ho freddo e ho bisogno di tenere la mia
giacca ma c'è in questo momento
all'interno non c'è bisogno della giacca
quindi sarà dunque facciamo trovare se
ti io sono una persona molto freddo nota
che qui mi avevano anche a nome al
rumore rumore
ho sentito un rumore di pacco di
patatine festa per qualcuno all'interno
del bar ticket sono serissimo donna di
quella va detto che non si possa più
piccolo non ho capito che cosa vi
facciamo crollare valeri siete pronti sì
ho bisogno del nostro aiuto qui alla
sala 1 da che cosa anni ho visto
qualcosa nel caduto di tutto e di più da
quella già cambiare aria fredda con di
snack propone giacca sequestrata fosse
sdraiandosi certo ma la prego una bella
ciao e la truffa ma di chi me la tengo
bellissima la demo mi sta bene
buffa round fallito la prossima volta
devo provare un metodo migliore anzi
consigliate melo voi nei commenti
chissà cosa starà facendo ora
con la mia giacca prezzi meteora proverà
a nascondere gli snack in un salvadanaio
vi ricordate l'altra volta io nascosti
nel pupazzo e lui non se n'è accorto e
quindi mi trovo dentro il salvadanaio
anche se si dovesse accorgere che c'è
qualcosa tentano salvadanaio penseranno
non posso romperlo per aprirlo devo per
forza romperlo ma in realtà si può
aprire d'acqua ed equa che infilerò gli
snack alla fine del video dovrete
scrivere nei commenti qual è il turno
che vi ha fatto più ridere che vi ha
divertito di più e se non l'avete
scritto nello scorso video in cui
nascondevo lisma e andate dopo questo
video a vederlo ea mutare il vostro
turno preferita purtroppo anche qua ci
saranno cose molto piccole ma meglio di
niente
vediamo di questa città definite le
caramelle si stanno pop corn pop corn
volontà di tintin e berlina sta questa
che sta cercando di prendere qualche
giorno perché merlino ad ora i pop corn
e eco fatto guardate pieno di pop corn
speriamo che non se ne accorga ora
dobbiamo richiuderlo con il tappo è un
rumore un po strano ma io farò finta di
niente è certo penserà che un pò strano
che una persona si porta il salvadanaio
al cinema ma mi inventerò qualcosa
[Musica]
a questi aspetti si cosa è quello che
quello che ha in mano è un cliente la
poesia grazie e può fregare l'altra mano
ma in questa io volevo chiederle quali
stati i nomi di malati posso scegliere i
dubbi di roma 67 avere nuove uscite sono
proprio qui all'inizio della fila
abbiamo il titanic super wars il dong
parla di una grande grandissima nave
dove vede per protagonisti due
bellissimi giovani nel loro cane ea
temere super morti invece super wars
riguarda appunto di un di un cane e
della sua padroncina che viaggiano in
questo mondo stellare fantastico con le
loro spade laser dovranno difendere il
mondo l'umanità e le altre diverse
location che super bowl artista bene ti
prego si accomodi sono invincibile
non mi sfugge niente sono troppo bravi
ci si sono bravo invicibile infallibile
il migliore
nessuno potrà entrare quando il cibo con
avete visto ragazzi se non riuscita a
distrarlo chiedendogli dei nuovi film è
stato che si sente un po dare il mio
salvadanaio pieno di snake è arrivato
anche berlino per mangiare gli snack
pieni
vi ricordate il mini pop corn
quale sarà il prossimo trucchetto un
trucchetto che mi avete consigliato vuoi
per nascondere gli snack nella
mascherina
io queste due vediamo quale più grande
così
conterrà più snack dentro questa a i
fiori ricamati forse più grande qualità
guardate che i ragazzi volta potrei
nascondere gli snack qual è il destino
della mascherina vediamo guardate se
berlino che è molto curiosa sei quella
che sto facendo
lui vorrebbe mangiarsi tutto le stime 91
le vuoi mangiare queste cose bene sono
ben nascosti un pezzo che troverà
vediamo ora come vista la mascherina
sembra che a un becco
secondo voi se ne porterà o no spero che
non ti ricorderò proviamo andiamo
[Musica]
ho detto non stecca e bevande ma dove
poter avere bertoli snervante che
mostrino strana perché sembra che lei
ambiente e perché sono cicogna
ma che domande non si può andare
no devo controllare questa mascherina
sospetta marano ticino critica rispetto
alla fine sono granché alle fa troppo
grande e vi facciamo tornare mi sembra
come se li nasconda qualcosa da dentro
non certo un rumore strano proveniva
dalla sua mascherina perché hanno
incrinato nascosto dentro sembrano delle
caramelle
io sono per caso delle caratelle io non
sono per caso dei cioccolatini
no ci sono percorsi delle barrette
energetiche no c'è un piatto di pasta
[Musica]
non c'e niente scolastica e questi sono
sequestrati sala possa andare detto sì
certo il mio bottino cresce sempre di
più
prego ha scoperto il mio nascondiglio
nella mascherina nella tasca
eppure erano nascosti così ben si vedeva
che la mascherina era troppo grande sto
facendo ora con tutti i miei snack
sequestrati prossimo trucchetto
nasconderò gli snack
anche cosa sono queste porcine per
capelli nasconde ronnie snack invece i
capelli sperando che non se ne accorga
magari riuscirà tipo una pettinatura
strana da pat forma importante che non
se ne accorgerà proviamo in effetti
questo potrebbe sembrare una decorazione
del fermacapelli guardate sembra un po
un fiocchetto vabbè lo copro così fu tra
i capelli va va beh proviamo ora a
mettere questi caramelle
wow
si trattano benissimo e bellicosi vero
questo pacco di patatine molto grande
non penso di riuscire a nasconderlo ma
proviamoci lo stesso questo trucchetto
troppo divertente quelle statiche
effetti natura fashion andiamo speriamo
che non se ne accorga
[Musica]
sto
per precisione come perquisizione non ho
niente addosso guardi indietro
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco tutto qualcosa dei capelli ribelli
è come il biglietto grazie vi facciamo
controllare all'acconciatura comunque si
accomodi
grazie signor primo fatta ora posso dire
e fermezza bellissime il pacco di
patatine
sì è proprio cascato alla grande persona
vostro dei farmaci che oggi un bel
bottino da portare a casa
carapelle ne sono già capo questo era
l'ultimo trucchetto chissà cosa starà
combinando era il controllore se volete
un altro episodio un terzo episodio da
state un bel mi piace e consideratemi
pure qua sotto nei commenti
gli altri trucchetti da provare e ora vi
lascio qua 4 caselline su cui cliccare
per vedere i notte altri video cliccate
su quella che proprio di deb una visione
ciao